Sherry's asking is it wise to buy email
lists I had a sense that this question
would be coming and again going back to
that roundtable as part of you know that
was a very hot topic because for the b2b
space and this is a conversation have a
one person about they're very actively
purchasing lists and when I you know I
just out of my curiosity I asked more
questions about where are they coming
from how do you get them and as she
explained the value of doing that and
that you know buying fifty thousand
names at a clip you know with certain
parameters was working in their mind
when I asked more about like okay so
where are those names coming from and
how are you sure and just kind of like
digging deeper you know my answer is
always gonna be the same it's it's
something that I would not recommend
doing because you know the hurt her
question was okay well then what else
how else do I you know grow list at
scale and when we started talking about
that content piece and the expectation
setting you know it was an avenue that
had not been pursued so again whatever
your industry of your product or service
there's probably some information that
you have that someone else would find
valuable that would help you grow and
maintain that list so I mean you know
short answer I don't agree with buying
lists and I'm happy to listen anybody
who's doing it and having success
because quite frankly that would be a
great education moment for myself to
understand how they go about doing it
but from from a hey you know from a
quick start to grow your list would
certainly recommend against it you know
you don't want to be in the business of
spanning people unsolicited emails is
not how you want to get out there you
want to build the relationship and I
think that the people it's tempting
because you want to do it fast right
like hey I want to get to a thousand
names ten dollars the names fifty
thousand names and when somebody says
hey I can get you in front of a million
people
it's tempting you know for only fifty
bucks right but if the deal is that good
you really gotta consider the quality of
that list right and I think your best
bet to kind of ramp it up again is to if
you're going to do some kind of email
partnership they have it as a
recommendation so if you're you know if
you connect with
if you can do something like me I have
75,000 people on my list and I work hard
to build up if I endorse you or say hey
come check out this product that I'm
using or this video that I'm doing
together that's the fastest way I think
to be able to build your list you can
piggyback off of other people but get a
genuine endorsement from people who
actually care about their list I think
you'll get a lot more success than just
buying names a great great